[music]
>> Hello everyone. Hello Laura.
Nice to see you all. Oh, nice.
Old face and new face.
>> It's always a pleasure to see many
familiar faces.
>> Always a pleasure to be at Station F.
So, for the little story, Hugging Face
started at the very first batch of
Station F
a long time ago now. We are 10 years
old. We did three years in this building
with three different incubators.
>> Great. So, I'm Laura. I lead founder
experience at OpenAI, or as I often say,
I work with people who are building the
future.
But today, we're here to talk about
physical AI, which is
what um I think everyone
>> We're both excited about.
>> Yeah, we're we're both extremely excited
about. I feel like I spent the day
talking to people about how people are
using Codex in robotics. But there's
never been anyone I've met who has a
better horizontal view of what's
happening in robotics and physical AI
than you.
Um we can talk about Reach Mini, we can
talk about Loobo, or we can talk about
everything that you're seeing. What are
you most excited about in robotics right
now?
>> In robotics, oh my god, there's so
[laughter] many things. I would say
specifically for here, I'm very excited
about uh the state of uh robotics in
Europe.
Because I think Europe has a as a huge
like
uh set of early or later stage
companies. Some of them I I've seen him,
some of them know for a long time.
They're very promising. I think Europe
has this huge like industrial history.
We know how to build stuff.
Um and I think robotics is interesting
because it's not yet a game of uh I need
the largest data center, and and that's
basically ultimately the only thing that
matter. It's a game of I can be smart
how I build my robots. I can be smart
how I train it. You cannot yet put uh 3
trillion parameters in in in a robot.
You're you're constrained by latency,
and that's also something that's very
nice for us. So, we can train small
models. You can use open source. So, I
think it's a it's a good it's a good
area where I think Europe can build
actually massive company.
>> Great. Okay.
So, as I said, you spend a lot of time
here. You talk to I I've never met
anyone in physical AI who doesn't know
you or doesn't already work a little bit
with Hugging Face. But not only do you
spend a lot of time in Europe, you go to
the US every month.
And every quarter or every few months,
you also go to Shenzhen. How would you
compare what you're seeing in the
different markets?
>> It's interesting, yeah. Um
I think people approach that very
differently.
Um
Maybe one angle to see that is
um
in Shenzhen or in China, people approach
it with a very
uh hardware focus. So, typically a
typical robotics team in in in China
will be like a team that's used to build
EV, and they start with a very strong
manufacturing angle in mind. They're
like, "Okay, how are we going to
mass-produce this?" You get then robots
like Unitree, very impressive. If you if
you go visit the manufacturing line of
Unitree, they test every single piece
for reliability. Every single piece of
the robot is tested over there.
Um and so, they really go quickly there,
but then they maybe spend a little bit
less effort or for now interesting in
the brain of the robots. So, typically
you will have this very impressive like
um I would say a hardware platform, but
like they don't really spend a lot of
time in the brain. I think the US is
almost the opposite. So, you go to this
company who are very like uh Apple so
they are like Nvidia, they're fabless.
They don't really build any robots, but
they are spend a lot of time on the
algorithm on the brain, right?
And Robot is somewhere in the middle.
So, if you go in ETH, if you visit like
Zurich, you see these teams, they know
really well how build robots, but
they're also like very ML native. Like
they are people who train I think uh
who know how to train LLM or who know
how to train VLM or world models. So, I
think Europe is nice having these both
talent. And it's interesting that if you
go in in the US, for instance, you can
categorize all the robotics company if
they are more hardware or software. And
you see very little company who have
both capabilities in-house at a high
level.
Uh maybe Tesla is one. And honestly,
there is very little. And I think that's
what's that's what's missing a lot in
the US. And in Europe, I do see that.
>> Um speaking of ETH robotics, uh or ETH
Zurich robotics, they have this robotics
club there that I get super excited
about because
I feel like Europe has come together in
a way that I've never I've not seen the
US or China or anywhere else to truly
build community. So, the robotics
community and the collaboration that
we're seeing in Europe right now is
quite unique in time.
So, the robotics club in Zurich was
self-organized by students, and they
have a project that is run across the
club where there's a team that's working
on each part of the robot. So, there's a
part that's looking at joints, there's a
part that's looking at the head, there's
a part that's looking at the movement,
there's a part that's looking at the
software. And they're all the different
teams coming together to collaborate.
So, there's a lot of learning that
happens. And then what they did was to
work with a lot of the other
universities around Europe and created
the European Student Robotics
Association. So, it's 14 of the top
technical universities in Europe with
over, I believe, 2 and 1/2 thousand
students across the geography that are
collaborating, that are hosting
hackathons together. So, I'm very, very
bullish on where robotics is going to go
in Europe from, especially, the younger
talent that we see coming out of.
>> So, let me ask you a couple of questions
as well. Uh
I know I've heard you recently became a
head of a global founders experience at
OpenAI. Uh Can you tell us a little bit
like what is it for a robotic startup to
work with Open AI? You know, where where
you can help, how does it work, what's
what's the founder experience when you
work with you?
>> first of all, I'll start with I'm
extremely fortunate because I had the
best job in the world. Like I'm I wish
all of you could have the joy that I
have. I get to work with founders and
investors and developers every day and
for 2 years I got to do that with the
best of the builders who are right here
in Europe and I'm
extremely happy that the team that we
built is now in working really well.
Whoever you are, wherever you are, if
you're in Europe, you will get to work
with the best startups team in the
world.
Um and Trisha joined and is now running
this team.
Um and every single person is the best
person I've ever worked with. So, now
that we have this fantastic team in the
startups, I got to move on to say okay,
well, as a platform, we do extremely
um
well in our developer experience telling
all of you how to get the most value out
of the models. How do you build and how
do you get to have all the benchmarks
and all the technical side? What is it
that you want to build? Well, on the
other hand, once you start
commercializing and once you start
building for others, how do you get the
most value out of the platform Open AI
as a partner so that as a founder you
have a partner for success, that we're
not just transacting and selling to you,
but from day one, the moment you decide
to build a company and you decide that
you're in service of that use case and
the users in that, we can partner with
you so that we're there from day one all
the way to exit so that we can really
see what it is that is a step change
um
in strategically using us for growth and
for value beyond the models.
>> Hello.
>> So, everything and anything that is in
sales.
>> And as a reminder, I mean, OpenAI was
extremely big on robotics. I remember
the the hand on the robotics, you know,
the Rubik's Cube. Maybe some of the
people were around in AI in 2000 I see
some of the people were
>> I have it in the office just right here.
>> 2019, yeah. The hand on the Rubik's
Cube.
I'm very excited. I mean, I won't ask
you because I guess this is all under
NDA, but about the new hardware coming.
>> Well, I'll tell you what. We are a
research and deployment company. We've
always done research and intelligence
and the very frontier of intelligence is
what we want to continue to always do
research on.
So, what is in research is very broad
and vast. Obviously, robotics goes in
there. Then there's product and then
there's deploying it. I work on the
deployment side of things. So, I don't
know what and when will come out of
research, but obviously, we're doing a
lot in making sure that we're at the
forefront of robotics research. If and
when something else comes up, we'll be
very happy to share.
>> I know some of our Richie mini came to
OpenAI. So, I don't know I don't know if
it's for personal use or for research. I
hope it's for research.
>> I've seen a lot of demos with Why don't
you tell us? Okay. So,
Richie mini sits on the desk. My
daughter uses it. All my colleagues now
use it. I walked in the office in Paris
yesterday and I saw a few on our desks.
There's little robot. We're seeing a lot
of humanoids here.
Tell us what you think about the
different form factors. Humanoids,
wheels, sliding. What do you think?
>> Yeah, I'm one of these person who is not
so excited about humanoids. I think
they're slightly scary. Every time I go
at night opening my fridge, I hope there
is not a humanoid just standing there
just I don't know being plugged and
I I think I don't really like it. I I
like the the weird form factors, the one
that, you know, they're rolling at half.
I like all these kind of Star Wars crazy
things that you like doesn't really
work, but why not? And I I think also
the nice thing is you
you can think about interesting things.
So, for instance, a humanoid
always have by construction a lot of
motors because you have like the 60 or
degrees of freedom you want. That's 60
actuators. So, like the the floor price
is always going to be quite high. So,
it's going to be really hard to push
that under 5,000.
And for instance, we want to sell $500
robots, which means $500, we're going to
have a walking robot soon this summer
that we're going to unveil. That's going
to be also 500 euro dollar or 500 euro
or something like that. Um I think you
can only do that if you forget the
humanoid form factor. If you go, "Okay,
let's let's imagine other way." So,
yeah, I think that's one thing I'm way
more excited about. I also think in
terms of even just human interaction,
it's even more fun to interact with
something that's not just in the uncanny
valley by construction, right? I feel
like you can think about new way to
interact. And then if you think, "Okay,
we're going to put that for use."
There's a lot of very interesting
companies here that are already
deploying like I was chatting with
Thomas from Sunrise just before I came
on stage. They're already deploying in
in in factories, right? And the the way
they decide is, "Okay, we're not going
to have something that move. We have
these like
um these like bi- bi- bi-
bi-manual setup and and basically that's
way enough for doing a lot of things."
So, I think you're way more free to
already using robots today if you don't
have to build to build a full humanoid
that's that's supposed to be able to
react to any any possible situation in
the world.
What about you? I mean, maybe asking you
as a I also know you you're I mean, you
help entrepreneur at day. I also know in
the weekend you're also investor in in
some startups.
In terms of physical AI,
you have some recommendation or some
advice that you always say to early
startups.
>> I mean, I'll tell every startup that
they should use
use Codex because obviously it's the
best tool for any engineer, no matter
what it is that they do. And I'm not
saying this just as that I work at
OpenAI and I'm an investor. It is the
fact that everyone that I spoke to here
told me an interesting use case that I
wouldn't have thought of. So, for
example,
um Benediktas who's over there from
Alana Inc. They're building a different
weaving
uh factor that could create the skin
skin for robotics.
>> Qualia is amazing, by the way.
>> Yes, they are. They're incredible. Um
Qualia is another company that was
started by a Swedish founder in Denmark.
And they're doing a lot of things that
are still in stealth, but when I speak
to him about how they're using Codex, he
said, "A, there is so much capability
now that comes from the multimodality
that Codex has. All the tests that we
do, all the agents that we build on the
back of it, whether it is simulations
and different kinds of simulations for
testing, whether it's creating a
database of what has worked and hasn't
worked in an experiment, so that we can
then create agents that understand what
hasn't worked and then create new kinds
of data in the back to further
understand and combine the different
experiments. Whether it is Orbit, which
is an incredible team that uses four
arms for robots in space, and it's it's
a team that comes out of ETH Zurich.
They've created a whole dashboard that
creates all the different parts of the
robot so that they have a command and
control center that can be used for the
robot, but also when the robot is
deployed in the different deployments.
So, you have a huge database that you
can build. Then you're creating
multimodality from the images, the
video, the analysis of everything that's
happening. You're using voice to control
and the bidirectional voice that we're
investing in over and over again. All
the capabilities of how the robots are
then interacting with the real world,
because for most people where AGI is
going going felt is in voice.
So, there's so much that you can do from
your control center from Codex that I
think robotics teams are some of the
most sophisticated users of agent
capabilities of it.
>> Surely.
And maybe by the way my my first
recommendation for them is usually to
not avoid the sophistication but to
really dive in it. So, the best team
we've seen and actually a lot of them
are also here from Paris thinking about
for instance Genesis really is very
impressive demo a few weeks ago.
It works when you dive really in all the
details of
how you train from the ML models down to
the firmware, down to how you interact,
down to the actuator. You you actually
need to go super deep in all these
vertical if you want to get a model that
really not only do this nice demo but is
actually something that push the push
the state of the art. I think there's
two things that that are really very
important to grab in robotics. The first
one is this, you will need to be
super technical and and technical on
a lot of aspect to really solve this
problem. And the second one is is data.
You will need to really
understand your data, clean it, find it
because it's way more complex than than
than for LLM. I think you need to to get
it and a lot of the challenge we we see
is around getting getting high quality
data, getting it clean, using the right
tools to like you are saying the
dashboard to visualize it, understand
which part of the data is interesting,
which part of what your robot is doing
is actually bad or good, which is way
harder in robotics because you can't
just
read it or just ask people to read it,
you have to watch it.
>> Yeah.
>> I think yeah, I think it's people need
to be extremely extremely technical.
>> Well, so I have a thing. Like I get very
excited by technical builders. And I
think in AI a lot of people can build a
lot of things. In robotics you truly
have to be technical. Like
you don't just wake up and say I'm going
to work in robotics.
But if you do decide to take up the
technical skill of robotics, the fact
that there's so much around it that
Codex can now do for you and how much
further, how much faster you can go is
really important. And like speaking of
sunrise, we were just having
conversation with Thomas. He was saying
things that previously would take months
are getting cut to weeks. Things that
used to take days are getting cut to
hours. And what is now in line of sight
of how to build the software around the
control of what is possible
is where the big delta is happening
because yes, we can build the
technology, but how does it get adopted?
How do you test it? How do you make sure
that it works? How do you take it from
theory and technical lab into people's
hands, into the factories, into
manufacturing, into logistics, into
operations, into the home, around your
kids and everything else in between. So,
robotics is not, as all of you know, a
singular
thing. It is all the things. It is how
you collect data. Companies like
Micro-AGI, who I saw walking around
earlier, and they're doing
the highest quality of data collection
to train robots and data sets, all the
way to the deployment and the control
and everything in between. So, given
this is a whole new intelligence layer
industry that is growing on top of what
we already have, I think we need to have
a blue sky where people have the power
to go into the innovation that is the
delta for what they want to do and bring
to the world.
>> I think Codex is helping a lot about on
that, right? I was just sitting with Jim
Jim Fan and the Nvidia is also here.
There is a lot of people. Jim is the is
the leader of robotics there. We were
chatting about this very impressive
project they have called Inspire where
basically they use they use an agent to
build the training the training loop and
to build the training recipe to train
the robots. I think that's really the
future which is you're going to use
these amazing coding tools, these
amazing like Codex, GPT 4 5.6
that I'm happy is out finally that we
can play with to basically help you
build this this research loop to create
your robots.
>> Well, I have to say on 5/6, the feedback
we've gotten is excellent so far and I'm
I'm I look forward to more people being
able to use it, but if I were to close
very quickly,
we're talking about a lot of things,
we're seeing a lot of things, we're
traveling in many places. What is the
thing you're most excited about or you'd
like to tell the audience or leave them
with?
>> Um
oh my god.
>> You want me to answer first?
>> Yeah, I'll let you answer first.
>> Well, for me the
as I said, the thing that gets me very
excited is very technical builders. The
other thing that gets me very excited
and is what's in my heart is community.
I love it when people build in public. I
know
right now there's truly the moment of
robotics and physical AI, but to see the
community come together and to see how
people are informing each other, but
mostly to see how much is coming from
every corner of
let's say Europe, EMEA, the world is
what I get most um
ambitiously passionate about because,
you know, Sunrise we mentioned comes
from Slovenia, but we've seen companies
in the Czech Republic, we're seeing
companies in Estonia, we're seeing
companies in Helsinki and in Sweden and
in Spain and like every corner of Europe
has a lot of history that hasn't
necessarily been tech first, but our
history that is uniquely incredibly
European is what gives us the right as a
community to become the leaders in the
world in this new technology and I want
us to see I want to see us win.
>> Words to live by. I think there's no
better way to end and I see it's
blinking anyway. Thanks a lot everyone
for listening.
>> Thank
>> Woo!